وحوش عملاقه عائمه مدن متكامله تجوب بحار
الارض ضخمه لدرجه ان مطاعم ومسابح ومدن
العاب ومسارح ودور سينما وفنادق جميع ذلك
موجود على متن هذه الهياكل المعدنيه انها
السفن السياحيه العملاقه
[موسيقى]
عام
1795 تم بناء اول مصنع لصناعه السفن
السياحيه العملاقه في مدينه بابنبورغ شمال
المانيا مصنع ماير الالماني بالسفن الذي
يعمل فيه قرابه
3300 عامل يبدعون في انتاج ثلاث الى خمس
سفن عملاقه كل عام اما الجاره فرنسا
فانتجت في حوض بناء السفن في سانازير هذا
الوحش العائم واطلقوا عليها اسمه اعجوبه
البحار او سمفونيه البحار
هذه السفينه مكونه من 18 طابقا وتتسع
لتسعه الاف شخص يبلغ طولها نحو 30061 مترا
فيها ثمان مناطق ترفيهيه تحتوي احداها على
اكثر من عشرين الف نبته وتضم اكبر منزلق
مائي في البحر واثنين وعشرين مطعما واربعه
مسابح واكثر من 2700 غرفه ومرافقها تشمل
ايضا متنزها مائيا للاطفال وملعبا لكره
السله بالحجم الكامل وحلبه بالتزلج على
الجديد ومسرحا يتسع لالف واربعمائه مقعد
ومسرح مائي في الهواء الطلق مع منصات
للغطس ذات ارتفاع اولمبي ولتشديد هذا
العملاق البحري انفقت الشركه المصنعه نحو
مليار و200 مليون دولار
بنحو 30 مترا من اكبر السفن العسكريه التي
تم بناؤها على الاطلاق وهي حاملات
الطائرات الامريكيه من فئه
ثلاث شركات اوروبيه تستحوذ على 90% من سوق
تصنيع السفن السياحيه العملاقه وهي
تشانتيرز دي اتلانتك الفرنسيه الاولى
عالميا في صناعه السفن منذ اكثر من 150
عاما تليها الايطاليه
والالمانيه ماير ويرث لكن المارد الصيني
بدا بالدخول على خط هذه الصناعه الامر
الذي قد يشكل خطرا كبيرا على انتاجيه
الشركات الاوروبيه
بدات الصين بالصعود تدريجيا في قطاع صناعه
السفن خلال السنوات الثماني الماضيه وفي
بدايه عام 2023 اطلقت اول سفينه سياحيه
كبيره
عمر السفن السياحيه العملاقه محدد ب 30
عاما وبعد مضي خمسه عشر عاما في الخدمه
تبدا ترتيبات خروجها من المسار البحري
الفاخر وتجربه رحله الكروس على متنها حلم
بملايين البشر حول العالم فهل سبق ان
جربته احدى تلك السفن السياحيه العملاقه